this is what happens when direct action
prompts a public reaction
[Applause]
anger erupted after a rush-hour train
was held up for more than ten minutes
and neither station staff nor the police
intervened with other extinction
rebellion members gluing themselves to
trains commuters couldn't understand why
public transport had become the latest
target they're doing it the wrong way
they're doing it for the right reasons
what they're doing it the wrong way
no one should do that I know everybody
so what is that's just our border and
it's not right they could have killed me
selves anyway I think they've really
shot themselves in the foot to be fair
um a lot of people getting public
transport as opposed to getting their
own transport
altogether three trains were halted by
rooftop protests very happy here you can
see a cameraman who was streaming live
pictures of the protest also became a
target as passengers lost patience a man
in the red jacket was punching in the
face a woman who was a commuter also
disrupted he was calling on him to stop
his violence and that was the most
shocking moment of the morning for me
altogether eight people were arrested
among them the Reverend super fertile
anglican priest by contrast this
extinction rebellion events has been
rated by because although they're
handing out leaflets they're not
disrupting any passengers journeys they
said extinction rebellion as a whole had
voted against halting trains the group
acknowledged it had been divisive I'm
not condoning the action XR will not
condone that action but I know what's in
their heart and why they were motivated
to do it and I I feel a little sorry for
them because they got themselves some
other passengers as well any of these
disruptions angry but the reality is
that if all protests look like this they
wouldn't get any media attention as we
near the end of the second week of X our
demonstrations only the most disruptive
action generates headlines and that
risks alienating the very people they're
trying to win over in woods at Sky News